John Wick is Keanu Reeves' most physical
role, and the actor has to be pretty ripped
to play the famed assassin. According to
Men's Health, Reeves used a surprisingly
limited workout routine to prepare for
the role, with just six central movements.
First, Reeves performs a reverse lunge front
dumbbell raise, which impacts the legs,
shoulders, and chest. Next up, there's the BOSU
lunge shoulder press. This works out the lower
body and shoulders, as well as developing balance.
Then there's the reverse-step resistance band row,
which continues the lower body
workout while also working the back.
There's also the squat with TRX shoulder
iso-hold, which hits the lower body and
shoulders. Reeves follows that with
the stability ball dynamic plank,
which develops core strength and balance. He
finishes with the banded lateral walk pallof
press, which helps to develop shoulder width
and leaves mere mortals feeling pretty sore.
The full routine ensures that a
person is both strong and mobile,
which comes in handy for martial arts training.